left-hander from valdez 0-2 the 2.04 era
in three games two starts 17 and
two-thirds innings 16 hits three walks
19 strikeouts so now the mariners have
runners on it first and third with one
out that will bring up third baseman
kyle siegert line driving left center
field over a springer to make the catch
tagging at third heading home with run
number one as dylan moore he scores
easily to the mariner 7 one-nothing lead
seger gets the job done now the one-two
swing and a mess got him on the fastball
valdez pumps his fist as he gets out of
the inning with just the one run strands
a couple
and after a half inning mariners one
astros coming up nestor cortez is the
man that's going to take the baseball
he's got three years the big leagues
pitching with baltimore new york and now
the seattle mariners josh reddick
punches another hit into center field
five-game hitting streak out of the
two-hole for number 22. springer will
now try for third and he'll get there
and redick into second ball miss played
by kyle lewis in center field cortez got
to pitch himself out of a jam here
swaying and a miss that's a good start
right there get him on a 3-2 breaking
ball one down so springer's still at
third reddick still at second and one
out for alex bregman
on the ground towards third diving stop
seeger no play anywhere bregman an
infield hit astros tie the game at one
so here he is his first at bat of 2020
the reigning rookie of the year in the
american league 3-2 pitches head deep to
left field you're done alvarez welcome
to 2020
puts one in the crawford boxes a
three-run home run in his first at bat
of the year
julie will drive one to left field this
ball's got a chance that's gone
back-to-back home runs from the cubanos
and the astros jumping out big against
the mariners with a five-run inning
back-to-back walks to correa and tucker
martine maldonado the number nine hitter
will come to the plate here in the first
down the line and left and that is a
fair ball that's going to score correa
tucker he's being waved home by gary
pettis he is going to be safe at home
plate the astros pouring it on with a
seven run first maldonado at third
springer at first here's reddick
breaking ball and that's pulled down the
right field line hooking will it stay
fair it sure will and it makes it all
the way onto the warning track maldonado
can walk home eight to one astros
on the ground towards the middle a
runway score and the ball's misplayed by
j.p crawford nine run inning and
counting that will load the bases for
jordan alvarez pitch to alvarez swinging
a ground ball diving stop it short by
seegers got it over to second for one
the relay to first and it's in time for
the double play and the inning is
finally over muriel homer going back to
back with jordan alvarez
as huley shoots one to deep right field
all the way back moore looking up this
ball is off the top of the fence yuli
thinking about three la pena on the move
and he will get there with a slide a
home run followed by a triple he is
halfway to the cycle in the second
inning correa on the ground infield back
that's going to score a run jp crawford
makes the play
correa retired but he will get a run
batted in and the astros now in double
figures it's 10-1 in the second inning
now the right-hander's 2-2 to springer
swing and it's popped up shallow left
field coming in as gordon going out
crawford d is there and gordon makes the
catch and that will end the inning top
of the third jp crawford will lay things
off 3-2 is swung on a miss crawford goes
down on strikes and there's one away got
him on the fastball the mariners have
runners on first and second sends the
ball to center field george on the move
still going back and he will ease up as
he gets to the warning track two men
left on base 10-1
look through the lead-off single here in
the top half of the fourth inning here's
a shot to altuve on the ground over to
correa onto first base double play man
correa can make up for a lot of lost
time with that arm at second base can he
here's the one two
got him swinging strike three underneath
the
the bat of white and after the lead off
single and a double play valdez back to
the dugout pretty quickly one out and
one on for redick two for three and rbi
double under run score tonight that ball
is sent into shallow center field
crawford going out looking for help but
he can't make the play springer trying
to go first to third and george will get
in there with a head first slide
even in a 10-1 game george springer
always trying to take the extra base and
josh looks into the dugout shrugs with
his shoulders and his three for four
tonight guess who's batting with the
bases loaded for the second time tonight
he already has a three-run home run
tonight jordan alvarez oh
that's not what you want to have coming
back that is a tough way to get an rbi
jordan alvarez has a four run batted in
game hit by a pitch with the bases
loaded and it's a double for evan white
puts runners on second and third
that ball popped high in the air
shouldn't score a run who wants it
everybody converging and altuve takes
charge
and puts it away
swing and a miss nice job by brandon
bailey after second and third one out he
pitches a shutout seventh inning
mariners are down to their final
swing and out
miss this ball game is over
ty snead picks up a strikeout to end the
game that has to feel good for the
right-hander as the astros win it
tonight scoring nine runs in the first
inning jordan drove in four in his 2020
debut